خلف هذه الجدران تحاك خيوط سياسه موسكو
كواليس بواجهه علنيه تمثلها خمس شخصيات
تتبادل الادوار فيما بينها بخصوص الازمه
الاوكرانيه او العلاقات المتوتره مع الغرب
الدفه يقودها الرئيس فلاديمير بوتين بصمته
الذي يخفي جبلا من الافكار والخطط خرجاته
تتراوح بين ممارسه الدبلوماسيه
البراجماتيه الهادئه والتهديد والوعيد سيد
الكريم قد يظهر هنا صامتا وهناك عبوسا
قمطريرا واضعا يده على زر اسلحه نوويه لا
تبقي ولا تذر
الى جانبه صديقه الكبير ورفيق دربه الرئيس
السابق ديميت فيديف لغته تغلب عليها
التهديدات لا يترك فرصه الا ويتواعد الكل
بالجحيم فروسيا مستعده لتدمير كل شيء من
اجل بقاء روسيا هي عقيده تلقنها ويرددها
باستمرار
قائد الحرب الاول وزير الدفاع سيرجي شويغو
احد الاعضاء القلائل في الدائره الاولى
للسلطه الذين كان لهم نفوذ كبير تحت حكم
بوروسيال في نهايه التسعينيات وتحت حكم
بوتين يظهر ثم يغيب يوصف بخادم القياصره
وابي الجنود كما يسمى بالحرباء المثاليه
القادره على التحول لتحقيق رغبه الحكام
خاصه بوتين
في ساحه المعركه الى جانب قوه شويغو
مجموعه فاغنر بقائدها المثير للجدل
او طباخ الرئيس وذراعه اليسرى في حربه
باوكرانيا ينتقد قياده الجيش في كل فرصه
تتاح له خاصه حينما انحى باللائمه على
القاده الروس بشان مقتل عشرات الالاف من
فاجنر لانهم لم يكن لديهم ما يكفي من
الذخيره
اما سفينه الدبلوماسيه فيقودها وزير
الخارجيه المخضرم سيرجي لافروف تراه في كل
موانئ عواصم العالم بحثا عن الدعم وربطا
للعلاقات وتفسيرا لقرارات الكرملين
يشكك بكل شيء يدقق في التفاصيل والتعابير
معروف بتصريحاته القويه
وانتقاداته الشديده للغرب بلال البجدين
العربيه
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات